oh wow yeah yeah I know what you
thinking look how helpless he is can't
even change his own diaper
well can't or won't
diapers are all about power dynamics I
poop they wipe BAM I'm the boss we work
the book baby
we babies are having a crisis babies
aren't getting as much love as we used
to behold our mortal enemy no that's
exactly the problem
have you learned anything AIEE
the temple confirm making plans for
their newest addition
[Music]
but this baby has a good plan
we babies are having a crisis babies
aren't getting as much love as we used
to behold our mortal enemy no that's
exactly the problem
have you learned anything he me no what
have you learned about puppies nice
puppy No Jimbo puppies are evil Stacey
be better no I can't read what could say
[ __ ] period oh it's like they're having
their own little meeting watch desert
humiliating you got the right baby this
John I know how important this mission
isn't the company haha poop duty
I got a deal the BK ID yeah are you I'm
on a mission it's not enough love to go
around my job is to find out why don't
give me a double espresso and see if
there's someplace around here with
decent sushi I kill for a spicy tuna
roll read about
oh you look the kids are finally getting
along that's nice
the finals succeed with this mission I
will live here forever with you okay I
will help you but just to get rid of you
deal you come to me Oh No you're
watching you too okay shoot you on that
how we can back the guard I've never
been so she will need in my life better
bring nothing I don't we're not opening
our have it done to me what's all the
racket did he adorable oh I've got one
for you too
what mama green work the bus baby put
that cookie down
cookies offer closer
you